[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on s'en allait chassé par le cyclone et
sur la route on nous avait jeté mais
quand on fut près de l'île du rô on a
compris qu'on était arrivé on a compris
qu'on était
arrivé
l'île du rô semblait nous attendre l'île
sauvage dousinom
oublié on a percé sa glaise humide et
tendre pour y planter nos tente nos
pommiers pour y planter nos tentes et
nos
pommiers que c'était bon d'arracher les
bou de failles nos mains faisaient
reculer la forêt quand notre terre nous
ouvrait ses entrailles que c'était bon
di plomter nos Pomiers que cétait bon
d'y planter nos pomières
êtes-vous fou nous disait le
village connaissez-vous le rô de chez
nous l'avez-vous vu quand il est par
l'orage gros de la son qu'il pleut sur
le
bour -v vu dans ces grandes
colères plus dangereux qu'un Archange
brutal tous les 100 ans la chose est
légendaire qu ou C fois il nous fait
bien du mal on a gardé les amâess
barques car si Ron nous donne encore 20
ans chaque matin chaque heur est un
miracle le Siroco n'en laissez pas
autant la coco n'en laissez pas
autant regardez là c'est notre île
cantique c'est un poème un bouquet de
couleur c'est notre terre et c'est notre
Amérique l'au de s bord fait le tour de
nos cœurs l'au de s bord fait le tour de
nos
cœurs car tous ces jours où l'on courvit
les Ch
pour préparer le sol de nos pomines on
avait tant t besoin de racine que c'est
aussi nos vies qu'on a planté que c'est
aussi nos vies qu'on a
[Musique]
plant
bravo